I wish I could hug you.
I wish I could hug you too.
I really wanna hug you.
I also kind of like I'm in heels right now,
but I remember when we met at here, stand up over here.
This is like my real height.
We were in a party at, it was at Chelsea's house.
Yes it was at Chelsea's birthday party.
It was like I had you in a corner.
And I was like, "Me, me, me, me, me, me, me, me, me, me".
And I was like, I have someone cornered,
who's a foot taller than me.
And we were talking about flower beauty
and I brought you a whole bunch today.
Yes, yes, you're right.
My favorite lip gloss.
'Cause that's what girls do at parties,
if you're wondering, the cliche is true.
We were sitting around talking about lip gloss
and all things girly and feminine.
Yes.
And it is Mother's Day,
Yes it is.
So how would you like to celebrate Mother's Day?
Like ideally no BS, total honesty.
What would your ideal Mother's Day be?
Truthfully, if we could just like go to a park
have a sunny day and hang out, it'd be great.
Maybe, or maybe not, you know, have a little bit of wine.
I don't know, it depends on the time of day.
And also we got my daughter this kite,
and anytime it's like windy outside,
I'll look out the window, I'm like,
"Get the kite."
And we're, we're like determined,
we're determined to fly this thing.
So if there was sunny day,
a little bit of wind.
Wind, wine?
Wind, wine
kite.
And we'll find-
Yeah wind wine and kite.
Do you also have a one-year-old?
I do.
A little boy?
Yes.
And-
He was born right before, you know the pandemic started.
In February?
So he was born in February and then everything
started going crazy with the pandemic.
My last book, "You & I, as Mothers",
which were, you know, Mother's Day.
You mean this book?
Yes, yes.
I love that you have a copy.
I happen to have right here.
So that book came out in April.
So he was born in February,
everything with the pandemic got crazy,
and then I started my then became, you know
an online press tour for that book that came out.
So between the book tour and bonding with my son
and you know, my husband, my daughter
and all of us as a family, it was, it was very surreal.
But what was great was it was a lot easier for me
to run up and feed my baby and then run back
and get an interview or go back up and, you know,
be with my family or, you know prepare food quickly
for my daughter or whatever it was,
being able to be so close at that time
really, really helped.
Did you have this at all?
On my first kid, Olive, I just didn't care about anything.
Everything seems so trivial compared to this baby.
Like I couldn't focus, I didn't care,
I didn't know what to do,
I didn't know my place in the world anymore
except for this little thing.
I totally understand.
And that, that did happen with me.
And after the birth of my daughter,
I didn't know what was going on.
I was like, I struggled and I rarely struggle from anxiety,
that's not something that I do.
Like I've taken a lot of risks
and I would do things that weren't really safe.
Like I used to do some things that probably
most people are like, "Wow that's really dangerous."
Climbing a mountain or riding a motorcycle
or whatever it was when I first became a mom, I was like
this is what real stress is because you have, for me
it was like my heart outside of my body
and I couldn't protect this thing.
And, and I struggled so much with like,
how do I protect this precious little baby from the world?
I was really scared and at the time I was living
in the lower east side of Manhattan
and every like fire trucks roaring up the street
and I would hear like a firetruck,
and I would think that something was like a threat
to my family.
Like I was really hypervigilant.
I had the exact same experience
and I think we were similar.
Like you, you climbed Mount Kilimanjaro, right?
Yes, I did.
I mean that is crazy.
So basically what this boils down to is,
you climb Kilimanjaro, you're a thrill seeker.
You, I would, you know, sky dive and swim with sharks.
Great! It's so much fun.
You did crazy things.
The funnest, thank you for sharing
how scary it is to have a baby too.
I don't feel like that's the talk.
And it's terrifying.
People don't talk about it.
Yeah.
You don't eat, you don't sleep.
I felt like I was gonna vomit every five seconds.
I've never felt it's, I've never felt a feeling like that.
It's just being able to talk about it
and feel like you're less alone.
And I think that that is so important
and building community is something that I really,
I really take to heart.
And it's just so important.
Well, how did you multitask everything?
I mean, now you have a kitchen line, so, like you know
you're writing books, you're going on press tours,
you're having kids, you're a director,
you're doing everything.
Sure.
How did the kitchen line come on?
Well, I've been cooking since I was a kid.
I mean, my mother was a gourmet chef
and I've been cooking really as a youngster,
I would watch her in the kitchen.
But what's interesting is her way of cooking was very,
she was a very eccentric chef.
So she would make things like Peking duck
and like a-
Wait, tell me that story about the Peking duck.
This is just, this is just an example of the type
of things that she would cook and like makeshift
in the kitchen.
So,
she loves cuisine.
That was very hard to kind of, to do, right?
So she would get a duck, and she would blow,
first of all, she would sew up any hole in the skin.
You have to, I know this sounds gross, you guys
but you have to sew it up so that the air can't get out.
So she's sewing the duck.
And then the other thing she would do was,
she tried a fireplace below to say, you stick
into a little hole to get, cause you have to
get the skin away from the meat.
So the skin gets crispy.
So the fireplace below was a huge disaster.
So then she took a bicycle pump.
Right.
Up the cavity.
Yes, so you leave a little slit in the skin.
As she slices the sticks, the bicycle pump in there
and starts pumping air into this duck from a bicycle pump.
She gets the air, she gets the skin away from the meat.
She unravels a wire hanger,
she gets the hanger through the duck's head,
which was not pleasant to watch as a youngster.
And then she hangs it in her closet.
For how long?
She hangs it in her closet with a fan blowing on it.
So at least a day, at least a day.
Is that why you see all the Peking ducks,
like in the windows?
That's what she was trying to create in her closet.
Right.
So but I grew up,
and of course her Peking duck was like, incredible.
Did she like enhance your palette though?
Do you think you're a more-
100%,
but she would never be present with the family.
She was never there.
She was always cooking.
So she would create these beautiful dishes
and was never there with her kids to enjoy any of it.
So even as a kid, I was like, there's gotta be a better way.
And that really is the impetus.
I've been dreaming of my lawn, my culinary line for years.
And really the core is I wanna help people
be more efficient in the kitchen,
so we can have more time together with our loved ones.
That really is the crux of it for me.
So all of my products, they're solution-based,
they save you time in the kitchen,
they're also really fun to use.
And that really is the heart of the brand for me.
Like I came up with this line,
HSN is an incredible partner and it's just been so awesome.
And someone else who I know you love
that I'm obsessed with Ina Garten.
Oh my gosh, the best.
She's the best.
Why is she the best?
Cause I think so too.
You know what?
I think it's time for a Garten party.
(audience cheering)
Do you wanna try a Garten party?
Oh my gosh that's awesome.
The reason I love her is because I find her cookbooks
also to be something you can follow.
A lot of cookbooks, as a cookbook enthusiast,
make me feel like a little bit of a failure sometimes.
Right.
Hers,
I always feel like even if it comes out a little different,
it's okay.
I feel really empowered.
Totally, that's a great word because you feel like...
By the way, when it's done, it's always a beautiful dish.
Like even her book "Cook Like a Pro"
I'm just like, yeah, because as a home chef-
Yes.
I wanna cook like a pro.
I have every single one of her cookbooks.
Ina Garten, if you are out there.
I know seriously Ina.
By the way,
I love like I'm right under her.
There we go.
We want to push on social media,
we've never done this before.
Great.
Some might call it harassment,
some might call it a social experiment.
Borderline.
But we all want you to join this Ina Garten Love Fest
on social media.
And if you use the hashtag hashtag hashtag,
if you use the #DrewsGartenParty
to tell us what you adore about the "Barefoot Contessa",
like, let's do this.
I would give anything to have, you know
a Laura Prepon, Drew Barrymore, Ina Garten Garten Party
here on the show.
Oh my gosh that would be-
Could it ever happen?
That would be incredible.
(upbeat music)